fait beau un peu plus chaud et pour la
première fois depuis longtemps le québec
se lève avec une bonne nouvelle
l'épidémie coronavirus aurait atteint un
plateau
le feu de forêt il prend est en train de
s'éteindre dans la communauté et c'est
pour ça qu'on est en mesure
éventuellement doré ouvrir
progressivement
bien sûr il ya les ch et celle des le
nombre de décès toujours en hausse mais
les efforts des québécois commencent à
payer ce que ça veut dire c'est qu'on a
l'air d'avoir contrôler la transmission
communautaire de coeur le québec n'est
pas seule italie espagne france etats
unis depuis une semaine la plupart des
pays riches de la planète sont au même
point
c'est encourageant mais il faut ensuite
passer à l'étape suivante
la belge du nombre de cas évidemment ça
avait quand même dire qu'il va y avoir
des nouveaux cas qui vont se présenter à
tous les jours c'est jusqu'à le nombre
de nouveaux cas vont être de moins en
moins grand
jusqu'à temps qu'on espère
éventuellement atteindre un creux à 0 le
plafonnement des cas permet de commencer
à planifier la suite des choses
le déconfinement moi ce que j'aimerais
voir de la part de la santé publique du
gouvernement
si un plan un plan avec des critères les
américains rappellent les spécialistes
ont déjà annoncé qu'ils vont attendre 14
ans consécutifs de décroissance des cas
avant d'amorcer un déconfinement autre
condition avoir en main un très grand
nombre de tests pour suivre de très près
l'évolution de l'épidémie
au québec on attend toujours les grandes
lignes du plan gouvernemental
ce serait utile pour la population de
présenter d'une façon structurée comme
ça ça aiderait beaucoup aux gens à se
faire une idée un peu des délais qu'on
peut envisager puis ça rassurerait
beaucoup la population avoir atteint ce
fameux plateau est une étape importante
disent les spécialistes
c'est le signal qu'on peut enfin laisser
entrer un peu d'air dans nos maisons
étouffante
il faut réaliser que si on a des confine
pas et si on ne laisse pas la maladie se
transmettre un peu ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on est ont aplati la courbe tellement
qu'à s'étire sur plusieurs mois voire
années
ici nous mourrons d'un radio canada
montréal